let's do another random sub oh
we're gonna have another stafford so
it's white's move
i like how my opponent just challenged
me oh my opponent's um
high rated oh my phone probably knows
what to do as well
like close nerd excuse video okay let's
focus
um oh 2400
we've played once before
so probably what's coming is this and
this
and then i'm just trying to remember my
prep so i can blitz things out
probably queen f okay so queen h4 queen
f3 okay let's just go into it
f6 i assume my opponent is prepared for
uh
for this i'm pretty sure knight g5
otherwise g3 happens
i was actually i was looking at this
line recently computer will give an edge
for white but it gets really messy
really quickly
um might get messy in white's favor but
hopefully that won't be the case
okay let's develop the bishop
okay so i want to play bishop d5 which
maybe i can do right now
[Music]
um and then we might end up trading ah
but h7 hangs in the end
it's all castle now i fly castles i have
bishop g4
queen here i probably avoid the queen
trade
so now i'm defending against
white casting this way white castles
this way i'm in perfect position to
attack
uh that's a good move
now white castle's queen side i have
bishop a2 perhaps
it's already like not not such a
terrible position
um i am still
i guess down upon but my king's safe i
have the bishops there's some weakness
here now
i'm gonna go for f4
oh i guess i can't with the pawn on a2
so move to a3 so i'll play this move
there's a funny idea bishop g2 and then
rook g4
and then bishop f8 am i trapping the
queen
i don't immediately see how white saves
the queen
bishop f8 the queen's trapped that was
like a really weird sequence putting my
pieces on random squares
i guess there's this move
but i'm also having these ideas but okay
i'm
gonna win the queen oh there is this
move
no but then i take and the queen's still
attacked and still trapped
i feel like i'm on hamilton as this is
uh the same type of move amon played
um but he played against the stafford
so i can take this whoa it's gm inlay
thanks for raiding you're just joining
i'm playing kind of an intense game here
um this came from a stafford gambit i'm
trying to
defend my honor pride and glory
but i have two pieces hanging this is a
maiden one threat
someone give a shout out to minlae very
strong chess player
of this moon
how to do this
okay i wanna i wanna sack on
sacking doesn't work though
there's queen e6
that's probably the best move
okay i was so excited i thought the
queen was trapped but it wasn't trapped
okay let's storm with a pawn i still
want to maybe play this
let's play this first
okay trying to use some bind in the
position
it might be threatening this move
actually
and we're basically just trading and
it'll be equal material
undouble the pawns
play a4 a4 is a very important
positional move
i'm down a ton of time i think black
should be slightly better here
so all my pawns are on light squares
oh there's a cool mating idea too here
here
never mind or here
here please play king d4
oh i'm gonna flag looks like one flag
actually it's gonna be close
oh i'm so salty at least that wasn't
raided though
oh i need to hydrate myself after so
much
so much salt that's okay though that was
a fun game
i'll have to put that on youtube the
staffer gamut has been refuted
or this is how you re refute the
staffing gambit
i don't know and dirty flagging
after 121 moves how many moves did we
play
when i was under a second
or under two seconds yes i i fell below
two seconds on move
85 and i
play your fighting instinct is strong
can i explain how it's not a draw it's
not a draw because
i'll show you why because this could
happen
so if this position happens white wins
so the bishop is actually enough mating
material
when there's a pawn on the board
i hope that makes sense and this is
according to feed a rules
if this were played on shots.com bishops
a single bishop or a single knight is
considered insufficient mating material
um because in most cases it's usually
there's no realistic way of meeting
um and even if i had like a center pawn
the the way i could still get mated it's
kind of um
what's the right word dumb it's kind of
dumb but
um imagine i wait
imagine this happens
and then i promote tonight and then i
walk the knight all the way
to g8
wait let's check though
yeah okay so basically if we get this
position
so this could work with any pawn where i
under promote tonight and then get this
position with me
it's like the the theoretically possible
mate that would just never happened
so oh does chess.com well trust.com will
declare
the game a draw if there is one player
flagging
um
like if i flagged on chess.com in this
position
it would be a draw because opponent only
has a bishop but
yeah it's not a big deal um
the the more interesting aspect of this
game probably of course the opening but
probably um
this moment when i played bishop f8 i
thought i was winning the queen
but bishop c4 is of really it's actually
the only move not to lose for white
and i should have been kind of alert
that like can counter-attack the queen
because i saw this and then takes and
the queen's still trapped
um as a cool sequence though
so yeah i guess i revealed some just a
little bit of
how i approach this position i do get
the question from
time to time how to deal with this and
then this
uh there is uh the trap
if white plays d3 here second most
played move on each s
then bishop's e5 and black is winning
because of tactics if takes we win the
queen
king e2 there's still this
and then yeah i've shown this probably
many times in various videos
this idea
so after d4 queen h4
so another trap is g3 runs into this and
then this
so my opponent knew yeah played the
like one of the best moves and i was
still prepared
oh i forgot about bishop g4 i played
knight g5 here
yeah bishop g4 i should play first
taking advantage of the fact there's no
f3 because the
athon's pinned
and there's some interesting lines um
i don't think i've ever shown this one
but if
knight g5 imagine white castles
then knight f3 is winning for for black
it's kind of a cool idea
here it takes takes and then it's hard
to not get mated as white
so yeah it's still fun to play in blitz
because
positions can get really crazy really
quickly
anyway um if this goes on youtube um
i don't upload too many i guess i don't
lose too many staffer games but um
i guess i should post more stafford
content where i do lose
so people can see i'm not fully
invincible
so people on youtube hope you enjoyed
that
please stay subscribed or subscribe if
you haven't already
oh yeah and twitch chat is always being
so welcoming
saying hi to youtube yeah especially
oh yeah especially mr kusha chess
who got a game because they were a sub
and
they were patient too okay
so we're moving on